what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and one of the projects that fans seem
to be most excited for coming in phase
six is the reboot of the Fantastic Four
in the MCU especially considering the
fact that Kevin feige the president of
Marvel Studios is putting a lot of time
care and effort into making this movie
an incredible fantastic pun intended
movie and of course the big question is
the one that fans want to know is who is
going to be playing The Fantastic Four
members well there have been a lot of
reports and a lot of rumors going around
about who the members of the Fantastic
Four are going to be played by we've
certainly had a lot of names thrown out
there but today it looks like we are a
little bit closer to getting an official
answer as it seems like Adam Driver is
going to be taking on the role of Reed
Richards in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now we might also possibly know
who is playing Sue's storm in the MCU
and it looks like like she might have
been cast actually before Adam Driver
and it looks like he is in final talks
with Marvel Studios to lock down the
role of Mr Fantastic we'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video and also don't forget to leave a
comment and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on the MCO and enter our
giveaway for a chance to win some big
prizes like a PS5 Xbox series X and
Marvel stuff and more we'll talk more
about that at the end of the video so
this report today is coming from Insider
Daniel rpk from his patreon account and
Daniel rpk has had a really good track
record over the past handful of years
when it comes to Scoops and this morning
he said Adam Driver in final talks to
play Reed Richards and the Fantastic
Four reboot now we've talked about this
before but right away let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below do you think Adam Driver would
make a good Reed Richards I definitely
don't think he's the first person that
came to everybody's Minds when they
thought about who Reid Richards is going
to be in the MCU especially since he is
so associated with Star Star Wars and
kylo ren however Adam Driver as an actor
has some serious Talent so let us know
if you can see him play and read in the
comments down below now this is actually
not the first report that we've gotten
about Adam Driver possibly playing Reed
Richards a while ago I'm talking about
four five six months ago we had some
reports from some Insider specifically
one was Grace Randolph stating that
Disney was talking about the role of
Reed Richards with one of their Star
Wars actors a big actor now some people
thought that they could have been
talking about John boyega there were
some rumors that perhaps Marvel Studios
wanted to have a person of color playing
read Richard so John boyega came to mind
however as more people started to talk
about this it seemed very clear that the
person they were thinking of and talking
with was Adam Driver and this makes
sense he was with Disney before because
Star Wars is with Disney so the
connections are already there Disney
tends to do this a lot use actors that
they've worked with before that they've
enjoyed working with because why not it
just makes sense if these actors are
right for the role now having said that
I know Kevin feige would not cast
anybody unless he thought they were 100
right for this role and since this
report states that he is in final talks
to play Reed Richards that means they
have chosen him they're just working up
a contract right now now that doesn't
mean that it's official and it's going
to go through but hopefully that is what
it means and hopefully we can get an
official cast announcement soon maybe at
San Diego Comic-Con maybe another con or
some Marvel event that they decide to
put on now as I mentioned Sue storm
might have already been cast about two
weeks ago John campia on his show the
John campio show came out and said that
he has heard personally that the
Fantastic Four have already been cast or
just Sue and read he's heard that maybe
all but if not those two specifically
have been cast already and I'll bring
this back to a previous rumor that
stated that Marvel Studios was looking
to cast Sue's storm first and then build
the rest of the team around her build
the chemistry around her specific
character The Invisible Woman now we've
heard many different rumors about many
different actresses who could be playing
the role of Sue storm but there are a
few that seem to be a little bit more
solid than the other Jody Comer being
the first person she definitely has the
Sue storm look and she is really tight
with Disney and to top that all off she
is really tight with a particular Marvel
character who is about to make his MCU
debut that is Deadpool her and Ryan
Reynolds did free guy together so you
have the Disney connection and you have
the specific Marvel Cinematic Universe
connection with Ryan Reynolds there and
what's also really interesting is that
she was in a movie with Adam Driver not
too long ago the movie The Last duel and
Jody Comer in interviews had nothing but
really positive things to say about
working with Adam Driver and she said
that she actually has a great respect
for him and that he had a great respect
for her and with Adam you know I just
think there was a there was a respect
there and we both wanted to do our best
then be equally as vulnerable you know
as each other and we both just made each
made sure that each of us was
comfortable so it's entirely possible
that Marvel Studios Kevin feige
everybody over at Disney think that the
two of them already worked really well
together they have a specific look
they're looking for and could put them
together I definitely think Jody Comer
has that Sue storm looked more than Adam
Driver has the Reed Richards look but
let me know what you think about Jody
Comer as Sue storm now another rumor
about who could be playing Sue storm The
Invisible Woman was Amanda Seyfried and
this is also really interesting because
her and Adam Driver were in the movie
While We're Young together where they
actually played a married couple Now
Kevin feige has already told us that the
Fantastic Four reboot and the MCU is not
going to be a traditional origin story
we know Kevin feige loves to be
different and we've heard some reports
that the Fantastic Four are actually
going to be so far along that they're
going to be parents in the MCU they
might already have their children
Franklin and Valeria side note Dr Doom
the uncle of Valeria Richards who saves
her life and ends up being the reason
that she is actually born could be
coming to the MCU soon and I actually
think Adam Driver would make a really
great Doctor Doom over Reed Richards but
let me know what you think about that
but if we are looking at a Fantastic
Four team that has already been
established in the MCU they already have
their powers Sue and Reed are married
already and they have their kids already
then Adam Driver and Amanda Seyfried
would make a really good pairing they've
already played a married couple on
screen they know what it's like to work
with each other already but the same
thing also goes for Jody Comer they've
worked together already they know what
it's like the two of them fit very well
together they have respect for each
other and they've both worked for Disney
this seems to just make sense so if they
have cast anybody for the role of Sue
storm rumors point to Jody comer or
Amanda Seyfried possibly being Sue storm
and it looks like Adam Driver is going
to nail down being Mr fan fantastic of
the Fantastic Four unless something goes
incredibly wrong like scheduling or
something like that according to Daniel
rpk's report Marvel has decided they
indeed want Adam Driver to play Mr
Fantastic they are just locking in the
final details of the contract for him to
play it plus this lines up with the
previous reports that we've gotten in
the past where insiders have told us
that they are looking at a former actor
from the Star Wars franchise the newer
Star Wars franchise that is now as far
as the rest of the cast of The Fantastic
Four goes Ben Grimm aka the thing and
Johnny Storm the brother of Sue storm
AKA The Human Torch we really haven't
heard much about who could possibly be
playing these roles anytime recently but
it is safe to assume that they would
want to cast Sue storm and Mr Fantastic
first because Sue Storm's brother is
Johnny so they would cast Johnny kind of
based off his sister so they could kind
of look like they're related but also
have good chemistry together that
brotherly sisterly Bond also kind of
ribbing back and forth and then of
course they would cast Mr Fantastic
before Ben Grimm they are best friends
so the chemistry definitely has to be
really good between the two of them as
well but it does look like we are
getting pretty close if we're about to
get our Mr Fantastic if we have Sue
storm already then obviously the next
castings are for the Human Torch and the
thing and go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about who should play these two
characters and really all of the
Fantastic Four in the comments down
below please don't forget to like the
video and again don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment on the
video so you can enter our giveaway for
a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
and some Marvel Legends or DC items the
winner gets to pick and we're picking a
winner at the end of each month you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf